la pandemia de coronavirus sigue
cobrando fuerza y debilitando a un
sistema de salud ya precario en tres
semanas el número de contagios diarios
en uganda aumentó de 100 a 1700 en este
hospital de kampala la atención es
palpable
la reserva de oxígeno que necesitan
nuestros pacientes pronto serán
insuficientes hoy podemos atender a 200
personas
william aquí pero cada día llegan más y
en algún momento no seremos capaces de
cubrir la demanda
[Música]
con las 900 camas que tenemos en este
hospital
ante el aumento de los contagios el
gobierno impondrá nuevas medidas de
restricción sanitaria están prohibidos
los viajes al interior del país y el
toque de queda nocturno se prolongará al
menos seis semanas más
uganda como el resto del continente
africano ha visto un veloz incremento de
los contagios
en áfrica case de sad increased by fit y
en áfrica los casos han aumentado en un
52% en la última semana y las muertes
han aumentado en un 32% por ahora sólo
se espera que la situación empeore se ha
vacunado menos del 1 por ciento de la
población africana
los mil millones de vacunas prometidas
por los miembros del g7 a los países más
pobres empezarán a entregarse solo a
partir de septiembre